what up anime fans goes on Animal Care
and today we're going to be talking
about pokemon go is it ruining society
is it destroying society and its really
important guys because as you can see we
have the title and all caps now um first
things first our channel has been
growing pretty fast lately and we just
want to thank everybody we appreciate
the heck out of you guys and that's
right I said heck I went there man
everybody seems to be into pokemon gold
it's really popular obviously but there
it does has it have its haters as well
people who think that Pokemon goal is
just way out of control that it's you
know either stupid or did its destroying
society and where again that it's
childish Pokemon go hate is real yeah
it's right back but we've even found
some articles and you can check those
out in the description about you know a
guy playing pokemon gold while driving
and hitting into a police cruiser which
is like the worst thing you could
possibly do um or some guys getting
apparently shot at while playing pokemon
gold because they were trespassing um
yeah like a whole bunch of crazy crazy
stuff so yeah there is there seems to be
some real issues going on with pokemon
gold but there seems to be you know a
lot of hate out there that that's just
kind of like oh it's childish it's for
kids whatever so I don't know it's let's
talk about that let's see what's going
on what do you think goes it well first
of all I think always you'll have
problems with stuff like this right
before people in cars like there's been
plenty on like issues and talking about
people playing pokemon going cars and
yeah it's horrible but you can't blame
the game I mean people have been texting
all the time they still packs they do
other stuff so people find stuff to do
you can't blame a game for that you know
you know what I mean yeah it's like
people are talking were like oh someone
you know might get hit by a car while
playing pokemon go cuz they're looking
at their phone but I feel like people
who do that would do the same thing
while they're texting right so it's
thought I don't think it's unique to
Pokemon go it's like obviously if you
use your common sense you know that you
can't you know be distracted while
walking in a dangerous area while
driving you shouldn't do that you should
never play poor one go and drive just
like you shouldn't talk on the phone and
drive just like you shouldn't text and
drive right so like I feel like calm
sense people common sense are going to
know that and people who don't have
common sense if they don't do that kind
of stuff with Pokemon go they might do
it with something else right so I I
would out said it's not pokemon gold to
blame there it's more like you know our
the mentality of those people who are
not focused enough not concentrated
enough on what they should be doing yeah
definitely and now let's just go through
some pauses because it has been getting
a lot of hate and just just the whole
idea of people using it as I can excuse
to do something else like there was a
scooter shop and it had like if you ever
feel stupid about riding a scooter that
think they're grown adults playing
pokemon go so that's like a god that's
like a common kind of idea and it's like
how is exercising you know having fun
you're usually it's a social thing as
well like it's been huge for just
socializing like a lot of people like
there's there's been a problem in Japan
for a while right people don't want to
leave the house there it's what is a
Kiki colony which people don't want out
like you know they fear leaving the
house and usually like they like video
games and they're like anime and they
like that kind of stuff but here we have
a video game actually taking people
outside like I think this is beautiful
like thing in Japan and everywhere
because it's forcing people to actually
go outside to exercise which is super
healthy and to socialize which is
healthy as well and I work out like as a
hotel front desk guy and literally I've
had people come to Niagara Falls from
Toronto from different parts of America
and Canada and just say that they came
here to play pokemon go it's huge and I
had people say that it changed their
lives and that it actually helped out
like before they used to be a recluse
like you know they used to stay in the
house now go out but this is gonna be
cool cool this is this is god I'm like
Fran's got like confidence so like I
mean it is huge it's a positive thing
and I think the haters are missing out
all these positive things it's a cool
thing to hate because it's like you're
either for it or against it but I feel
like people should do some research and
see all these positive things about it
and focus on that rather than just the
few negative instances that people use
to say it's bad like the few car
accidents when you ignore all these car
accidents because of texting
other stuff yeah so i will say Niagara
Falls is a huge book mango hot spot and
we actually have a vlog out on that if
you want to check that out but um goes
in here is more the more dedicated
pokemon gold player a lot of the two of
us I a more like casually he played he's
the one that plays and records the Let's
Plays for our channel he's the one with
the high rank CP de he wish he wishes he
was me whatever yeah so he's the guy
battling the gyms he's the guy doing all
the poem girl stuff so he is very Pro
Pokemon go but I think there is you know
some things that we can talk about that
are some negatives so me I was around 10
when pokémon go first came out so just
like ashes a dried so for me it was it
was like something i could really relate
to i love pokemon as a young kid and
then now that pokemon goal came out i
can kind of live out those childhood
fantasies of being a polka master by
playing pokemon i was sick as that let
me just like cutting it like there are
people who are making videos on YouTube
about Pokemon and their Pokemon
adventure and it's literally their
full-time job like these people are paid
to be professional Pokemon trainers and
hopefully become a pokemon master like I
think like we should take some time to
just appreciate how amazing that is and
how sick this world so how much time do
we need to take just like stare at the
camera for static a moment a moment of
beautiful or acknowledgment okay enough
but though I think that a lot of these
people that don't like it are the people
that didn't watch the original Pokemon
they were too old so now they're all
like making fun of the you know the
younger folks kind of like oh you guys
are now in your 20 is your adults but
you're still catching Pope commands like
what's wrong with you but it's like they
didn't I hate when people say pokeman
pokeyman pokemons let's pokemons plural
already okay but but I think that yeah
it's basically they don't get it they
didn't live through the Pokemon crazy so
they can't relate as much but I feel
like there is one thing that I noticed
well like pokémon go over the summer um
sometimes you know I feel like right now
we go out less for nature walks and just
kind of appreciating nature which we
used to do more last summer because
we're doing a lot of Pokemon go logging
and a lot of
because we want to put the videos out
and you know one time I was out we were
going on filling up on our pokéballs and
polka stops and things like that and we
it was in a really nice park and I
started looking around I was like you
know what I'm gonna put the game away
i'm gonna put it away and just enjoy
this nature just listen to the birds
singing just you know look at the
beautiful green or the trees you know
the bush is because i decide i thought
that you know I feel like Pokemon go is
in the next to an extent bringing us
away from that like take us you know
we're looking at the screen so even
though we're out and doing is exercising
moving great but we are not stopping to
smell the roses I guess you could put it
and I think that so you definitely
balance in that regard so what would you
say that I feel like there is a fair bit
of that is true but at the same time I
feel like pokémon go has like me panic
book [ __ ] is not gonna prevent me from
enjoying the nature around me I mean
most of the time you're walking and you
have the phone like let's say in your
hand and if it buzzes you'll see what
kind of Pokemon it is and that you'll
like catch it but it's like you're
always looking at it and I gotta say
playing pokemon goal has brought me to
such cool places into such cool natural
surroundings as well you'll see our
newest blog as well like there's a
quarry behind Brock that's absolutely
beautiful and I definitely always take
the time to appreciate the nature when
I'm out taking these walks and sometimes
I like put put the phone away for a bit
and just appreciate it but I feel like I
would have even been there if I didn't
see that there were Pokemon gems they're
so this is actually gave me to discover
cool natural surroundings that I
wouldn't have known about and I I'd say
almost makes you appreciate nature more
because I'm discovering stuff I didn't
know what's there and for a nematic you
can blame us not going on nature walks
as much just to you know you're being
lazy too if you don't have to play
pokemon whatever no no I'm not blame for
one go but clearly this guy is got you
know where these fans on the whole
question of his pokémon go destroying
society where I
where I stand is I feel that it has you
know it's all about balance like any
game you play if you're playing in 12
hours a day there's something wrong
you're going to be missing out a lot of
things in life you're going to be you
know it's gonna be affecting your
relationships and all these kind of
things but if you know you know when you
can when you should play and when you
should you know back way put the game
away stop to smell the roses hang out
with your friends hang out with your
girlfriend um I think you know if you
can have that discipline then Pokemon go
absolutely it's not destroying society
but obviously if we if positive effects
man if we have a lot of if we have a lot
of people addicted to Pokemon go in
there like just losing it um then it's
an issue but it's not the real issue is
not pokemon gold then it's it's the
people that are not as disciplined it's
the mentality it's the you know lack of
perspective and lack of priorities right
so it's Brooklyn go destroy society no
but the only people that can destroy
society are the people themselves and I
just want to add that that's true you
know you can your life can't be booked
long ago you gotta step away from it
sometimes but at the same time I feel
like it can actually you does not be
relationships or Pokemon go because like
me and my girlfriend both play pokemon
go so actually something to do it's I
can go on Pokemon go dates even where
you just explore new areas yeah no no we
won't go dates bro that's true that's
our roommate huh anyways okay so yeah
Pokmon go like you can use it to explore
new places and you can smell the roses
and play pokemon go at same time it
doesn't have to be one or the other you
can step away from it sometimes but yeah
I think overall it is a very positive
thing we've been hitting like our 10,000
steps at least a day since book one goal
which was very rare before even with the
jogging I had trouble hitting 10,000
steps with Pokemon it's been almost
every day hitting the 10,000 steps so I
think it's doing wonders for people in
general people just got to be careful to
not let it control their lives and to
obviously if they're driving or doing
something important to focus on that and
not focus on Pokemon go and of course
instead of taking your girlfriend out
for dinner take her to catch some
Pokemon you can do both
thanks guys till next time see you space
cowboys